bismillah al hamdulillah assalamualaikum
greetings of peace to everybody all over
the globe I want to give you a short
introduction about my guest on this
week's show who at the time when we were
filling filming the show he was with me
he was very buoyant happy excited as you
can see to share to get out there this
would he lived for propagating the truth
he was an advocate of peace calling
people to p's calling people to the
purpose of life he was somebody who was
out there working for Humanity to make
the world a better place and it's sad to
say that he has passed away and I send
my condolences to his family so when
you're watching the show think about it
think about this man who at that time
was alive and he was at the peak and the
pinnacle of his life but now he's gone
he's left he's left his life but he left
behind some wonderful work something
that will carry on with them into the
next life he left a mountain of good
deeds may Allah accept it from him with
the crater accepted from him may his
family continue his legacy of sharing
this message of peace with the world so
we asked that the crater grants him
Jenna Mae everybody make dua for him and
really think when you're watching the
show that def he didn't expect that it
would come at that time but it came and
it's coming for all of us so let us live
a righteous a good pious life a life of
morality a life that is on the oneness
of the Creator doing good calling people
to good and living in peace and sharing
this message of peace with the world
enjoyed this week's show thank you
you know this is the days of Athene jus
this is the day the bismillah al
hamdulillah Salaam alaikum welcome to
the Dean show I'm Eddie your host and
today we're going to be talking about
something that's very very important you
already agree and we've covered this in
so many shows but we always we always
are very excited and anticipating
there's a lot of not yet Muslims who are
tuning out for the first time so Islam
is based on five pillars the most
important of which is that you establish
a direct connection with the one who
created you that's the one guy the same
God of Jesus Abraham Noah Moses in the
last and final message said of mankind
of problem home and peace be upon him
now once we establish the first pillar
and the rest of them we also at the same
time have to be perfecting our manners
and that's what we're going to be
talking about today here on the Dean
show with my special guest Imam
Mustafa's aid when we come back sit
tight everybody in deep down they
believe that there is a God yeah and as
much as they deny
if God exists and he does if God sends
prophets and he does if God reveals
books and he does should he not tell me
how to live my life doesn't that make
sense they feel more secure and safe now
inside the religion of Islam than they
ever felt out in the streets
but the best way to bring true profound
happiness trooper found peace trooper
found tranquility is by following the
guidance that God has given see for
yourself what Islam has to say because
it really is the path to happiness and
truth in life so now l'ecole said I want
all of our cats please be with you thank
you brother is that why I'm the lot of
enemy now you said something in Arabic
now it's see people are like Eddie you
keep repeating these same things but
look I know the Muslims know these words
but I love those who are our brothers in
humanity who we want to be our brothers
in faith and they hear some Arabic words
please define what you say I said hum de
los anomaly i said praises be over
thanks be to Allah Subhan Allah Allah
creator of heavens and earth and I say
jazakallah khairun male lost power you
would do well which is the best reward
of them all the reward from our Creator
toss inshallah now keep you know what
just keeps sending and non-muslims to
the Dean show because they get a free
arabic class at the same time yes and
they get to learn about by default by
the fall and they get to learn about the
most misunderstood way of life but isn't
it the fastest growing way of life in
the world today Islam absolutely there
was a statistic by CNN for the past 15
years not one single religion or a
denomination of fun religion grew in
America period there was only one
religion that was Islam and it doubled
in size doubled doubled that's a messy
teen years now with all the hype
negative media publicity I mean what's
going on here I mean did the Muslims pay
off these some of these big shakes pay
off CNN absolutely to the contrary some
of our good American brothers actually
some sometimes they are incensed about
what they hear about in the media about
Islam and they go let me go to the
library and see what is that you know
religion they're talking about and the
more they read without any middlemen
without any biased or people of special
interest they understand the truth of
religion and the understand Islam and
they embrace Islam never one time in the
past 20 years that there was high
against Islam that was not accompanied
by a higher ratio of amer
has accepted Islam amazing amazing
amazing and manage is what we're talking
about yes yes manners what define
manners in slaw what is it how important
our good manners behavior in Islam if
there's anything more important than the
manners of Islam is actually the
certification of the oneness of Allah
soprano Todd problem Hamas ISL and peace
be upon him defined it better than
anyone else he said in my life to luton
minimum academic left I was only sent to
complete the most noble of manners the
entire message of problem homicides
edematous struggle over 23 years was
about completing the best of manners
manners in Islam is not my perception of
good or wrong right or wrong my
intentions or my idea of what is good or
was to be done it's how practically I
proved my belief in God in dealing with
every living entity around me even
animals even Adam even animals problem
Hamas is Elam forbade his companions to
have a standstill conversation while
they're riding their horses horses that
are bred and fed and raised to carry
people he forbade his companion saw a
lawyer sell em to have a conversation
you can have that conversation you foot
why you impose your weight on the backs
of horses Wow he would be walking and a
cat trying to drink from a part of water
and the level of the pot is higher than
the cat the Prophet SAW is Ellen would
kneel down tilt the pot tell the catfish
is drinking and walks away and then he
will continue walking so the religion of
Islam is about your behaviors not about
my good intentions or my perception of
peace and love and and compassion it's
how I apply that and how I fear my
Creator in dealing with his creations on
a daily basis our Islam is founded in
the message it but it's practiced
outside the measured with every one
Muslim non-muslims even animals now you
mentioned some examples some beautiful
examples of manners I mean behavior
towards animals yes what about now
towards fellow human beings promised slm
defined a Muslim by a very simple
definition a Muslim is the one whom
people all people Muslim non-muslims are
animals are safe
from his hand and his tongue now labrada
that was that me from his hand when it's
gonna slap upside the no no a hand means
if steal anything that the hand can do
anything to Hank even if you send an
email that bad biting someone that's
anything that can be of harm to human
beings or live beings around you that is
if people are safe from that from you
then that's the definition of as the
hand can do a lot of bad you can smack
some upside the head and actually you
can if you think about it your tongue in
your hand are the main tools for
interacting with people yeah it's how
you affect other people yeah one thing
that I want to bring not only our Muslim
brothers but non Muslims also the Holy
Quran that one final untampered with
with word of Allah Subhan Allah Allah
which version of the current there's
only one virtually one the only Holy
Scripture in the same original language
the same way that was revealed to the
Prophet form Archangel Gabriel given to
people exactly as it is for the past
fourteen hundred years that is the crack
is this a living miracle it's absolutely
yes absolutely it is the same exact
words from Archangel Gabriel as revealed
to problem homicide Selim are in your
hands in a life language that is called
Arabic that you can learn not right now
well that's another topic of itself but
go ahead please but in that miracle that
that you just mentioned of a holy
scripture that the most repeated phrase
in the entire for n is 55 times levena
MN llama dos Allah had those who
believed and did righteous deeds based
on that belief those who believe and did
righteous deeds upon that belief now the
belief real quickly real quickly what
does that believe one almighty god one
mighty God you believe in all his
prophets the original scriptures that
were sent to them in the angels of god
Hellfire Judgment Day paradise and the
faith that a loss of power that I had
ridden with him for every single
creation of his in the keytab mubeen
when he created the universe and then
you said you follow it up with wood
action that's no good action yes talk is
cheap so exactly not the perception of
good and bad nutin the emotions that I
have on my heart and love and compassion
but how I apply that practically when I
deal with people if I truly believe in
God and the room is empty and I couldn't
do how long I can steal I can cheat I
can lie nobody's
watching and I stopped myself I said no
God is there God is watching me I would
stop in fear of god that is belief
that's a good deed to then right
absolutely because maybe your desire
wanted to do some baddest you've got
pushed up and control yourself from
doing what your self likes but in fear
and obedience to your career isn't that
in Arabic jihad yes just drive striving
against the time ago echinacea sup you
absolutely look and the highest you know
and that's one of the biggest misstep
shins about Islam is jihad striving
prognosis Irma ask what is the best kind
of jihad because in the Quran you can do
things for the sake of allah subhana
allah strive with you money with your
knowledge and soup so he was asked what
is the best kind he said a word of truth
28 ironical ruler Wow let's take a break
Ann's back for more here in the D show
piece what happened to my best friend I
don't see him here in general la opens a
window so he can see his friend in hell
he looks at his friend doesn't it you ok
can I pull you out he doesn't say that I
said man you almost took me to the party
with you you're the one used to crack
jokes with me about religion know that
you're that guy and then now imagine
this guy who's in Jenna looking at this
and saying oh thank God I didn't listen
to you because for a second there I was
thinking about it he just saw Hellfire
he comes back into Jannah and it's like
he just got here for the first time the
words in the Quran are amazing if I
might not know given your team are we
not gonna die anymore really oh wait you
already knew that he's a jungle but when
he saw a glimpse of hellfire the most
beautiful thing you could appreciate
about Jenna first and for like it's a
reintroduction to Jenna was the first
thing he says I can't you're not gonna
be tortured there's no more pain that's
the second thing he appreciates why
because he just saw what pain looks like
some hot Allah back here on the D show
with imam Mustapha je all the way from
New Jersey how are things out there
hummed a lot but I'm hamdullah all right
thank you very much again for making the
time to come to be was with us actually
thank you for having me thank you so
we're talking about good manners good
behavior and if the Muslims if we would
live like the last and final messenger
his son his way more
we'll be coming to islam more people
we'd have less problems but it's because
of our lack of good behavior mannerisms
and now it's following the blueprint we
got a lot of weird a mess yes so tell us
now define for me good manners not
according to what we perceive good
manners being but as to what all the
prophets Moses Jesus knowing the last of
elements of Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him what he define and they define
good manners as being that's a good
question from Hamas slm defined good
manners in three parts yes and you'd be
surprised the first part is guess what
what's a bus to watch to have a lenient
smiling laughing face he was described
by his wife s ada aja he was the most
laughing and smiling and welcoming of
all phases we should smile more
absolutely all right a lot of the
brothers confused their seriousness
about their Dean that they have to have
a grim and serious and you know face
they're emulating someone that one is
not problem homicide asylums and this is
also very good when you are with people
that do not know you that's how they
know that you know what this someone
that I can talk to this someone who
might be courteous and helpful to me the
second part is careful other some people
translate that wrong into not harming
people no it's stopping yourself from
harming people when you can harm people
when you able to avenge and retaliate
and you stop yourself you say for the
sake of God I'm not gonna hurt and I'm
gonna forgive and I'm gonna party
promise I sell em once was walking and a
big one who was obviously new to slam
the prof mama says Ellen did not know
what so ever came from behind
performance I seldom held them from his
clothes and shoved them so violently to
the right that the close of the Prophet
Sal I seldom made a mark on his flesh
promise slo-moes the most powerful men
in the airport Peninsula when there was
a battle the the bravest of them all
used to hide behind him for protection
amazing problem on Salem could
physically split them into two pieces
what would he do he smiled at the man
and told the Companions standing next to
him give him from the Muslim Treasury
the man was yelling at the Prophet give
me from the money of God that He gave
you he was asking for charity but that's
his way you've asked from home smiled
and asked the man giving from charity
and turn around did not say anything to
him he could have been she could
retaliate but he would forgive and he
would part
careful as a stopping oneself from
harming yeah the third part is bezel
model and a lot of people do not know
and this is actually a serious problem
what is the highest level of a Muslim
according to a slammer according to the
Prophet of Islam who is the best Muslim
is it them the Muslim that praised the
most or faster most or read Quran the
most no higher onesi and found the nest
the most and the best of all Muslims are
the most beneficial to all people all
people meaning muslim non-muslim animals
all p how beneficial to every living
soul around you that would make you a
better muslim or for that matter the
business we can possibly be these are
good manners tell us now someone says
you know what I like that smiling part
you know that's good that's good so the
brother we catch him you know looking at
somebody's not and say hey look I heard
on the D show that you know I should
smile more so she or he is smiling at
the opposite gender say hey I'm just
trying to you know Noel else my haha
allowed smiling jela that's a good point
ok so this is uh for how's that defined
that just elaborate on that a little bit
so that's also modesty is in the
mannerisms also that we conduct yourself
when you said something allow halal
means you know of everything Allah so
panel Tyler put up as you say always
blueprint for us blueprint and the
blueprint is only for your benefit yeah
whatever the lhasa panel said Hallel
that's pretty good yeah whenever said
Haram Haram actually if you look at it
it's the same word as spelled as harm
with one different letter yes harm you
whatever that harms you whatever that
hurts you whether you are wearing fur or
not that's what I lost prom is haram for
you it's all for you benefit any
protection lots of Hannah tonight we're
of the universe that is 13.8 billion
light years wide does not mean you
charity or your bowing or whatever that
you do he put you in a test are you
going to be grateful to the life that I
gave you or not are you going to be
courteous and helpful and forgiving I'm
pardoning a merciful to people or not so
when you come on judgement day at the
day when the result of the test happens
and you ask a lot of her mercy put me in
paradise forgive me put me in paradise
part of me put me in paradise a lot of
how asking were you merciful when you
could were you forgiving when you could
did you party people when you go were
you grateful to all the bliss is that I
gave you for free or not and that's what
life is about yeah we've kind of got
away from that I mean
when you say manners most people think
about helping the old lady across the
street open in the door for somebody
saying thank you you're welcome now we
do those things and do we go beyond that
absolutely it's you behave your manners
as you behavior these things are nice
things and they're good etiquettes and a
good etiquette is a good manner but
about the generality of things
everything are you beneficial are you
courteous are you hurtful or you know
are you a source of help you know
helping people and caring for people
that's what the whole religions about
its how to practically show what's in
your heart now people are getting a
different perception here because many
people from maybe just watching the
media or maybe even I mean you have some
Muslims who aren't acting in accordance
with Islam so how do you differentiate
you know the person that might have son
seen a Muslim acting opposite to what
you're saying say hey man this is what
you talking about gibberish because the
Muslims that I know they're not acting
like this they might be swearing I see
them at the nightclub you know they're
not opening your doors for me they're
acting totally opposite of this how do
we differentiate what you're saying you
know from the actions of some who are
doing the opposite that's a valid
question but the answer is even simpler
yes there's a difference between the law
and the criminals aslam is the law that
criminals should be judged by when they
commit the crime the law is not judged
or shaped or the identified or defined
by the behavior of criminals these
Muslims will not abide by the law they
committed the crime of you know not
obeying Allah Subhan Allah but when you
compare their behavior and try to judge
that Islam is that is this simply you
are judging the judge and the court
system and the law by the behavior of
the man who just broke the law itself
which is that makes early a lot like you
says the answer is simpler than the
question yes amazing amazing we're going
to take another break and we'll be back
for more here on the D show it comes to
you the truth
and the attribute of the one who created
you that he's one and alone running this
universe that he doesn't become former
he doesn't die he doesn't eat and go to
the bathroom this is not God your
problem cheers yeah is this doesn't make
sense who was Jesus worshipping this is
recorded in the Gospels despite all of
the other issues about the Gospels we
put those aside to say expansion there
that Jesus worship God one from hunger
back here on a Dean show with Imam was
tough as a now when I started the
program we mentioned the five pillars
one of which is the most important that
one he acknowledges what's ingrained in
its very nature that there is no god but
the one god yes man is not a god woman
is not a god but the one who created man
and woman the one God creator of Jesus
Moses Abraham the problem Hamid peace be
upon him they all worship the One God
yes now there's a foundation then the
establishment the prayers five times a
day paying of the secod the poor do tax
and the fasting during a month or my dad
and the Hajj so now this is heavy on the
scales yes but now when you compare
mannerisms some people might be doing
this but now they have bad manners and
they don't repay their debts they gossip
they backed by getting in other people's
business yes is this all under the
pretense of good manners and how heavy
is it when you implement good manners
actually that's a very good question
because the very famous hadith that
almost every Muslim knows that hadith of
the pillars of Islam Islam was built
upon the five pillars that he said the
most important and key word and that is
is duniya built upon this is the
foundation of a building you don't dig a
huge hole put concrete and you know
fortified steel and just level with the
ground and walk away that's the
foundation of the building of Islam the
building of Islam cannot be found
without that foundation but the
foundation is not the entire building of
Islam now what is that building that
building is the mannerism of Islam
promises and instead of colum- dolphin
is any lab dilma climate the heaviest
thing that can be put in the scale of
final judgment day not reading quran not
fasting not know where phil it is host
not Hollow and taholah talk aloha
fearing Allah subhana Allah
and good manners and if you think about
it fear and last one good manners are
the two sides of the same coin I feel a
loss of Hannah Tyler I'm not going to
hurt I'm not going to gossip I'm going
to be you know courteous I'm going to be
helpful i'm gonna be charitable i'm not
gonna say a foul word i'm not going to
hurt anyone with whatever strength that
i have whatever blessings there are lots
of how that had given me I'm gonna use
that to get closer to a loss of chanukah
and not to transgress and hurt people
with and that's the essence of his lap
and that's why Islam spread and still
spreading exponentially the largest
Muslim country in the world Indonesia
you know there was no battle to open
Indonesia first land was for merchants
when they went to the market after
accepted Islam to the shock of everybody
they said you know what before we quote
you the price this is what's wrong with
that piece of textile this is what's
wrong with that horse before they quoted
people prices people were shocked and
after the Dunder business people ask
them we never seen that honesty and your
demeanor and your cleanliness what's
going on what do you call that they call
that slab and these in divisions that
actually ask that question and accepted
islam they do not accept islam as a
title but the mannerism of islam that
these people showed and they showed that
and that's how 230 million Indonesians
are Muslims today that is amazing it's
amazing and the seriousness of good
manners because isn't it also emphasized
that now you can be praying and you can
be doing all the acts of worship but at
the end of the day on the day of
judgment if you did all these evil
things that you're going to be losing
your good deeds if you had bad manners
gossiping backbiting you know being
deceitful lying all these this is bad
manners aren't you going to lose your
good deed actually praying and fasting
and charity all these obligations all
these pearls of Islam is to strengthen
you believe in got so much that you go
outside and show you the manners of this
lab so there might be a deficiency in
your prayer because it's supposed to
make your manners babs alee the good
manners of Islam is the fruit of a man
yeah you have a tree that the root of
the tree is the belief in the oneness of
God the worshipping is the trunk of that
tree and then when you worship correctly
and you have the correct amen and the
solid a man you could see the fruits in
everything that you do and deal with
people and that goes back this is
another topic of itself you should know
what you're saying in the prayer some
people going up and down
exercise but if you're not benefiting
from that prayer benefiting meaning now
it's not changing your life helping you
to stay away from evil developing your
character there's some maybe deficiency
in your prayer even by definition
promise I seldom talks about the reward
and Salah lucuma kelton a new prayers
what are you going to get the reward you
get is what do you comprehend any
prayers that's where the reward is we
prayers is not an exercise of bowing and
moving you back or just moving your lips
you need to understand and fear loss of
Hannah and mean what you say as if Allah
Subhan Allah Allah is standing right
there before you so that goes back to
really knowing Islam reading the car and
the verbatim would have got with
understanding knowing the example of the
last time but worth understanding the
reason for the Quran is to make the
double to comprehend Quran a lot of
people think that Weeden the Quran is
you know phonetically pronounced in the
Arabic words yes there's a reward for
that from Allah subhana Allah but the
purpose of the Quran is for us to
comprehend it and apply it in when we
dealing with people with in our
practical manner but some people you
know they kiss the Quran they put on the
shelf and now you go you got it comes
out and somebody dies and they'll read
the Quran got a bunch of dust on it is
that with the crime was sent forth no
Quran is that's actually the blueprint
for o mankind to live the most
fulfilling satisfying joyful life on
your way to paradise there's meaning
there's logic there since their spirit
there's this everything that you need in
your life and even the Sunnah of Prophet
Muhammad's enemies tradition is came to
explain that for an and make it easy for
us by the practical example of the
manners of pro from homicide amazing
amazing we're out of time how can people
get ahold of you and you're also the
author of a wonderful book called the
lies about Muhammad peace be upon them
how can they get your book and how can I
get a book is available online
insha'Allah it's on amazon.com
barnesandnoble.com and actually you can
follow my blog and my recent articles on
the lies about Muhammad common chalo
amazing to me thank you very much they
got almighty the Creator Allah reward
you does ekalaka don't you thank you
manners in Islam and Islam by now you
know that it means to acquire this piece
that we're all looking
for by submitting your your your wants
your needs your desire to submit your
will to God's will to the craters well
this is Islam and then we talked about
manners I don't know about you but I
love to sit with people such as
anomalous toughies eight other people
scholars that we've had on the show
because this is how we be come better
Muslims through knowledge then
implementing the knowledge by action
it's amazing keep coming back here to
the Dean show to learn more I'm learning
more I'm getting excited learning more
because the more we learn about Islam
dorm or it just entices us to do more to
to be better human beings to to be
better husbands sons daughters I mean
this is the blueprint we got to learn
the blueprint we got to live by it and I
hope that you really got to benefit I
sure did we'll see you next time here on
the Dean show until then peace be unto
you